cette vidéo est sponsorisé par une
maison d'édition est un média 100%
indépendant
la relève est là peste je vous en parle
en fin de vidéo reste et c'est important
j'en peux plus du comité
[Musique]
c'est la première fois où parfois j'ai
l'impression de perdre la bataille
psychologique quoi parce que c'est ça
dont il s'agit en fait macro il ya un an
quand il parlait de guerre bat pour les
soignants et les hôpitaux c'est une
guerre sanitaires mais pour moi et la
plupart d'entre vous c'est une guerre
psychologique en fait c'est s'ils ont
vraiment et le passé me manque de ouf je
parle pas d'être en couple avec
quelqu'un qu'on aime et qui nous aimons
retour même si c'est de la balle quand
je parle de débarquer à des restaurants
des délais au cinéma enfin juste remplir
son agenda en fait mon agent d'âge le
consulte tellement moins qu'avant c'est
terrible quoi il ya juste quelques visio
pro de temps en temps et donc là à
l'heure où je fais cette vidéo on ne
sait pas s'il va y avoir un troisième
confirmant enfin a priori s'il y aura un
troisième but mais on sait pas quand on
ne connaît pas les modalités
voilà moi je vous avoue que je vis déjà
un petit peu comme si tout était confiné
voilà c'est juste que le peu de chose
que je pouvais faire je peux vous avez
pu les faire quoi c'est tout j'en ai
parlé à ma mère elle m'a dit cyrus tu as
une responsabilité
tu as une audience il faut que tu sois
positif c'est vraiment c'est vrai c'est
long je tombe sur un article d'une meuf
qui s'appelle amélie en avril dernier
alors été déjà son troisième confinement
parce qu'il était à mouran elle a été
confiné ensuite à une quarantaine et
ensuite a été confiné en france et elle
expliqué dans l'article qu'elle n'en
pouvait plus quoi on pouvait déjà plus
en avril dernier
je me mets à sa place un instant amelio
est tous derrière toi quoi ses excuses
regarde toi
accroche toi ça te plaît j'espère que ça
va et quand je dis on met tous derrière
toi j'exagère à peine
zaïre en fait je la norme c'est d'être
déprimé maintenant si pour vous
aujourd'hui ça va franchement je vous
dit entre nous gardez le pour vous quoi
c'est suspicieux on se dit cette
personne ne nous dit pas tout garde déjà
c'était chelou juste sourire dans la rue
ok alors que ça allait bien donc là avec
tout ça je te demande si ça va tu me dis
oui il ya un problème
g j'ai repensé
il ya un an comme ma vie était
totalement différente et comment en fait
le coc vide est venu tout mettre en
pause et je me rends compte seulement
maintenant c'est à dire alors un an plus
tard à quel point c'était une erreur en
fait ce terme mettre en pause mettre en
pause
nasser que on attend quoi on est là on
attend que ça passe on ne fait rien
jusqu'à pouvoir rpt et appuyez sur play
et donc reprendre reprendre la vie la
vie normale quoi ou pire l'expression
qui me donne vraiment des frissons dans
le dos la vie d'avant sauf que plus le
temps passe et plus je réalise et des
gens qui l'ont réalisée il ya six mois
accédera chacun va à son rythme ok mais
plus je réalise que en fait il faut pas
mettre en pause faut pas attendre la
tante faut l'éviter
je m'explique
[Musique]
j'étudiais une revue scientifique
française de psychologie cognitive qui
publiait chaque année est en fait
l'année 1914 étaient assez intéressante
il ya une femme qui s'appelle
mademoiselle morand j'ai pu j'ai pas son
prénom
j'ai juste mademoiselle morand qui a
parlé de la tente et elle dit à juste
titre que la tente c'est un terreau pour
l'incertitude le désir la colère la
crainte et l'impatience et l'image
intéressant parce que c'est à un point
où on fait le terreau se fait recouvrir
de ces choses là un petit peu comme des
mauvaises herbes
si bien qu' on ne distingue plus latente
de ces choses là mais c'est quoi en fait
la tente c'est quoi une attente pure en
fait 2 une attente des nu et tout ça
harper visant à définir mais il ya déjà
quelques éléments
il y a la prévision de quelque chose qui
arrive hockey et il y à l'adaptation qui
va avec
on va devoir s'adapter à cette chose qui
arrive il y à aussi et ça c'est un mot
qui est pas mal employé par bergson
l'après perception c'est à dire l'art
présentation anticipée d'un objet et
enfin élément très important il y à un
intervalle de temps perçu c'est un
intervalle de temps qui doit pas être
intéressant c'est un intervalle de temps
qui a juste pour but d'être écoulés il
est vide c'est un obstacle en fait entre
l'événement et moi c'est une condition
sinequanone à la tente tout ça tout ce
que j'ai à me dire c'est ça la teinte
une fois qu'on a compris ça d'un point
de vue psychologique on réalise tout de
suite qu'en fait la tente ça un état
d'esprit quand on se retrouve dans une
situation de la vie tous les jours où on
doit attendre
bah c'est un choix on peut ne pas
attendre
on peut par exemple utiliser ce temps
pour autre chose ou bien un peu juste
apprécier l'instant présent juste
profiter du fait d'être et qui fait et
parfois je me demande si le fait que je
trouve le qu'ovide long
c'est pas parce que je suis dans cet
état d'esprit d'attentes au lieu de
profiter de ce qu'il y à a profité
ne serait-ce que l'instant présent et je
pense pas être le seul je pense qu on
est beaucoup à attendre la fin de sa et
que ça nous cause du tort que ça rend
tout plus difficile
s'il ya un an m'avait dit bon mon pote
trinh duc o bella en fait ça va durer
plus d'un an voire même deux déjà
j'aurais été ménagé à ben ali
définitivement
tant qu'à faire et surtout je pense
qu'en fait j'aurais mieux vécu les
choses parce que la tante alors été
moins forte
et d'ailleurs on sait même pas ce qu'on
attend on sait même pas à quoi va
ressembler la sortie de cette crise ça
dépend de plein de facteurs différents à
quel point une personne vaccinée peut
transmettre le virus à quelle vitesse
des communautés entières peuvent être
vaccinés la course entre d'un côté les
vaccins et de l'autre côté les variants
donc les mutations et donc vous adaptez
les vaccins et settat et potentiellement
l'avancé de nouveaux traitements mais
bon imaginons imaginons concentrons nous
sur le vaccin par exemple hockey parce
que c'est le truc qu'on a le plus avancé
aujourd'hui mais il ya plein de gens qui
veulent pas se faire vacciner par
exemple donc on fait quoi du coup on se
confie lui c'est ce que les gens qui se
sont pas fait vacciner change d'avis
c'est quoi le but on cherche les 8es
collective ok qu'est ce qu'on fait de
tous les nouveaux variants et qu'est-ce
qui se passe je ne comprends pas en fait
je comprends pas un choix ou on va quoi
tu vois et c'est même pas un truc c'est
même pas un rapport avec nos politiques
et à des décisions c'est moi même même
si je moi je pouvais décider de quoi
faire je sais pas ce que je ferai en
fait ben voila je comprends pas la
direction du truc quoi et c'est même pas
une critique envers l'exécutif parce que
même si j'étais à leur place je sais pas
ce que je ferai et ça les amis ça
s'appelle l'incertitude
[Musique]
c'est ça qui nous bouffe on n'aime pas
l'incertitude
enfin on se rend compte qu'on n'aime pas
l'incertitude on se rend compte à quel
point notre société à écarter
l'incertitude et ça n'a pas toujours été
comme ça en fait ça date de descartes
c'est ce que nous explique un philosophe
britannique du nom de stephen tout le
monde tout le minent
alan nan staff à l'humanisme de la
renaissance aux 15e et 16e siècle
accueillait la complexité le chaos du
monde
ok et au 17e ça change avec l'arrivée du
rationalisme je vous la fais très courte
mais en gros l'incertitude et
l'acceptation du pluralisme humaniste
aller plusieurs conséquences dont une
qui a été l' intensification des guerres
de religion donc l'époque elle avait
besoin de rationnel de vérité
incontestable qui permettait à la
société de s'unir et donc c'est des
cartes qui s'en est occupé entre autres
en s'attachant à des champs d'étude
abstrait dont qui n'était pas lié à un
contexte comme par exemple les
mathématiques donc on évite
l'incertitude et on veut masquer de
certitudes à on veut le menu certitude
triple xl frites ketchup et j'ai
l'impression que c'est seulement
récemment qu'on redonne à l'incertitude
une place notamment comme source de
liberté
s'il n'y a que des certitudes le monde
est totalement déterminée est-ce que
c'est l'histoire qu'on a envie de se
raconter
je suis pas sur ce qui motive la
connaissance c'est quoi bah c'est la
crainte c'est la crainte de l'inconnu
c'est la crainte de ne pas comprendre ce
qui nous arrive c'est la crainte de pas
pour se protéger c'est la crainte de pas
pouvoir se nourrir c'est la crainte
c'est ce qu'explique nietzsche et c'est
pour ça que derrière la volonté de
vérité
il y a une volonté de puissance mais où
ce que nietzsche le dit autre chose il
dit ce n'est pas le doute c'est la
certitude qui rend fou alors évidemment
on pense au fanatisme
on pense aux complotisme où il n'y a pas
de place pour l'incertitude et donc on
perd les gens mais au-delà de ça la
liberté
l'exploration elle est permise par le
doute j'écoutais la radio une interview
de dorian astor qui dit un truc très
juste et qui m'a aussi sauté aux yeux
quand je regardais une chaîne
d'information ou
il y avait un expert qui était
interviewé et les chroniqueurs qui pose
une question et ils disent je sais pas
je sais pas on attend les résultats on
attend les analyses bla bla en face le
chroniqueur le présentateur dit ok donc
la réponse est non qui dit non je sais
pas je ne sais pas je vous dis je sais
pas d'accord donc donc pour l'instant la
réponse est non et ça rend fou
on a du mal à avoir des certitudes parce
qu'on est dans une situation nouvelle et
on donne la pire réponse à ça qui est de
forcer les certitudes du coup c'est des
certitudes qui change
norman la situation évolue et donc c'est
hyper angoissant et chiant pour nous
arrêter de faire ça alors oui les
décisions politiques pour être suivies
elles doivent donner l'impression que ça
vient d'une certitude
ok mais ça fait un an ça fait un an
c'est bon on sait tous cas pas de
certitudes on a compris on peut tous
arrêter de faire semblant
réconcilions-nous avec l'incertitude et
appliquons là dans d'autres domaines de
notre vie par exemple le fait de savoir
si on veut se faire vacciner ou non donc
aller jusqu'au bout de ses raisonnements
aller jusqu'au bout de ses craintes
allaient trouver des réponses à ces
craintes tout ça pour prendre une
décision qui prend en compte les
incertitudes mais qui pour autant
réfléchi oui j'ai va vous empêcher de
parler du vaccin
oui mais c'est parce que j'ai envie
d'aller dans un bar j'ai envie de pons
et le dancefloor et j'ai envie de nick
et oui voilà je vous ai dit que j'en
pouvais plus ou pas donc d'abord on a
d'attendre on change état d'esprit et
ensuite on accepte l'incertitude
les deux vont ensemble c'est ce que je
vais essayer de faire dans les
prochaines semaines et je vous invite à
faire avec moi on s'en parle sur les
réseaux soient instagram twitter ou sur
ma newsletter voilà faisons ça ensemble
je pense que ça aidera à rendre les
choses plus faciles cette vidéo est ce
qu'on ne faisait par la relève et la
peste qui est le nom de médias et de
maisons d'édition le plus stylé au monde
je pense c'est 100% indépendant donc
s'avère que ils ont pas publicité pas
d'actionnaire donc plus on voit beaucoup
de thunes ce qui veut dire écoutez ce
message sponsorisés pour que ce soit le
plus rentable possible pour en gros ils
vendent des livres
voilà et avec l'argent de ses livres ils
financent leurs médias est donc l'heure
et d'acteurs et d'actrices et ses terres
par exemple en 2020 ils ont sorti vivant
où il parle de l'importance de protéger
la terre et d'être gardien du vivant ce
qui est aussi totalement logique et ils
ont eu des auteurs assez renommés comme
pablo ses vignes par exemple
ou lamya essemlali donc la présidente de
sea shepherd que j'interviewais extraits
donc si l'océan ne renoueront avec les
c'était un extrait très court on n'a pas
le temps on n'a pas le temps et animale
en 2021 qui est vraiment le seul livre
en france qui fait le tour complet de
l'extinction de masse des animaux
sauvages qu'on risque de voir
disparaître d'ici quelques décennies
si on ne fait rien ils ont d'autres
formats genre db des genres des petits
livres etc
voilà je vous montre pas tout pour que
ce soit le plus précis possible et que
vous perdez pas dans les messages cd
livres qu'ils sont beaux intéressant il
ya la forme il ya le fond c'est rare
franchement c'est rare parce que
généralement soit c'est intéressant et
c'est sean soit c'est trop beau et c'est
nul
voilà là vraiment il ya tout et en plus
c'est fait par des gens bien parce que
c'est des gens qui s'intéressent à ces
questions là donc vraiment foncer
merci à eux de m'avoir fait confiance
achetez les pas eu enfin papa palais
mais pas le média ni la maison d'édition
je parle des livres
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
venez on en parle
la sueur twitch voilà là je suis
sûrement sur twitch on regarde ces
vidéos si vous la regardez le jour où
essor et si jamais on m'a raté
j'y suis tous les mardis à 22h on met le
feu à la twittosphère on regarde des
docus des reportages etc
c'est de la balle tous les mardis 22
heures pur moment voilà love peace chao
et on arrête d'attendre et on accepte
l'incertitude